what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with a Fantastic Four now we're
in the thick of it now right we're in
the main story we're in the the the
Grand Puba of it so what we're going to
cover in this video is going to be
stupendously important that you remember
this because here in about two weeks
this is going to become an incredibly
important moment in the the entire comic
book run so what we end up doing here is
picking up with something called The Ark
and we're introduced to something called
the galactic not really introduced to it
more reminded of it but the thing about
this is that this basically starts off
with Reed Richards being summoned to the
Moon by Galactus right now the funny
thing about this is that when he gets
there Galactus presents him with
something called The Ark right and and
Reed's response is why in the world are
you giving me this like what's the
importance of having this right now
galatis literally says like you humans
feel the shifting of the wind I sense
when Worlds rotate from seasons of life
to seasons of death very soon your world
is going to be broken I cannot let that
happen when the time comes you are to
use that device read Richards and when
you do the ark will summon me and the
response of read here is okay but like
again why are you giving me this Arc and
why am I going to need to summon you
because at the end of the day one of the
things to keep in mind is that the whole
idea of Galactus or his role in The
Fantastic Four is to prevent his death
in the future remember that in the
stories that we covered before there
comes a point when Earth becomes
unhabitable right there's just no way to
save the Earth itself and that in an
effort to basically Stave off the
destruction of the human race that a
handful of that future superheroes right
so basically you know Banner Jr from The
Old Man Logan universe and so on and so
forth that they basically end up
fighting Galactus and then knocking him
out and then using his body as
effectively a time machine to send
themselves back into the past but that
process would destroy Galactus and so
the responsive read is okay but like
here's the thing if the Earth is
destroyed then there's no no concern
about the Earth being uninhabitable
which means no one on earth in the
future is going to kill you and use your
body as a time machine so isn't it in
your best interest to let the Earth die
and the response of Galactus here is no
because there is a Galactus seed on
earth now the reality of this story is
that this is more of a kind of like
Jonathan Hickman response it's a way to
basically consolidate continuity and the
reason why is that if I recall correctly
at around this time when the story was
being written I think it was Rick
remender who was writing Thor and he
introduced the Galactus seat and that
the way it was done by Rick remender and
then the way that Jon and Hickman does
it here is kind of reconciling it
Jonathan Hickman's kind of changing it a
little bit but that's why Galactus says
Diaz Guardians have it and they hid it
in the world tree before I could destroy
it and he says if the Earth is destroyed
it will release an anchor to the tree
and the seed will tumble through space
and time to places less accessible until
it is retrieved from the asgardians I
cannot allow the seed beyond my reach
now here's a kicker to all of this right
here's the thing behind the galactic
scene kind of the back story here and it
was actually mad fractions run not Rick
remember's run but the way this played
out is that during the Mighty Thor by
Matt fraction the Galactus seed was
introduced to us as a creation of the
cosmic entity eternity that quite
literally it would give birth to the
next universe and that the whole idea
behind this is that bore the father of
Odin had discovered the Galactus seed
and then used it to create the current
universe as it exists now I know it's a
little wonky and it's a little weird
when it comes to like the continuity of
like the universes and so on and so
forth that doesn't really apply anymore
and even Jonathan Hickman kind of cleans
that up a little bit and sort of
eliminating that whole idea of the
Galactus seed giving birth to like a new
universe and so on and so forth and
instead the Galactus seed gives birth to
what would be like a new Galactus
essentially and what he says here is
that if the Galactus seed is not
harnessed and taken by Galactus himself
that somebody would get their hands on
it and that if that happens and the
Galactus seed is born then that would
give birth to a new Galactus the concern
here is that Galactus would be immature
that it would literally just consume and
destroy everything in its path now the
reason why that's so important and the
reason why that matters is because for
the main Galactus himself that he is the
Survivor of a previous universe that
died he was born into this new universe
and then all the powers of the power
Cosmic itself is ambiguous as that power
source is that it was all imbued inside
of him and then he was born he consumed
archeopia as the first world that he
destroyed and then went forward as
Galactus the destroyer of worlds but he
has all those memories right that entire
life he lived beforehand as a scientist
and so on and so forth so he has
restraint he has the understanding of
what his role is he was able to
scientifically analyze it pretty quickly
and then realize he's there to maintain
a balance this Galactus seat right
whatever version of him will come out of
there will just be a new being who is of
the power of Galactus and they'll just
start destroying everything because they
literally won't know any better right
it's like a newborn child with the power
of God he would just go nuts right he
would literally just go crazy and so
with that kind of thing going on the
Galactus seed has to be harnessed and
contained and so what Galactus says is
when that time comes whether it's
because you discover the seed or because
something else takes place the seed is
discovered before I can get to it you
will have the ark summon me if you need
it but also summon me if a situation
arises where your world is going to come
crashing down right where literally the
world is going to crack and so it's like
okay cool like Reed and Susan get the
message and say okay cool thanks is
there anything else you need and the
response of galactuses actually yes
there is Reed and when Reed's question
is okay on top of everything else what
is it that that that you need of me and
the response of Galactus is with all
your focus on the world seemingly
tearing at its scenes everything going
on the different versions of you from
across the Multiverse who have shown up
on your world because I'm Galactus and I
need I see and know all with everything
that's happened read Richards have you
even noticed have you even paid any
attention to what your son has been
doing have you even noticed on the most
basic level that not only are Franklin
Richards powers back but your son has
been learning to control them that your
son has been learning how to alter
reality on a universal scale are you not
paying attention to that this is one of
the most important things that I want
you guys to remember this story right
here is going to come back because it's
going to be referenced and that moment
in the comic is only going to make sense
because of this video that we've covered
right here but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace